hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the
quarterfinals of the charity copy this
young sister of duda versus david
antongiharo uh and it is a brilliant
brilliant short game that features a
move that everyone enjoys uh i'm sure
you know
which i'm talking about uh so let's not
um i give it too big of an intro let's
dive straight into the game so do that
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 the royal lopez is on the
board we have a6 morphe's defense bishop
to a4
knight to f6 and now d3 this is the
anderson variation uh against the the
morphe defense and as you've finished
the morphe saga you have now increased
your vast knowledge to the point of
knowing why this is the anderson
variation to the morphe defense so
bishop to c5 and now bishop captures on
c6 this is all very well known stuff so
nothing out of the other ordinary here
the captures on c6 and knight to c3 we
have queen to e7 and now adding a
defender to the e5 pawn and h3 now
preventing bishop to g4 and now usually
knights to d7 is played here as this
position has been reached quite a few
times but here we have a5 uh and it is
now already as of move eight that we
have a completely new game all right so
black says all right i've grabbed more
space here on the on the queen side i
might play b6 bishop bishop to a6 i
might develop this way i might even play
b5 b4
if you allow it uh so instead of
allowing it we have a4 by duda
b6 preparing bishop to a6 and now knight
to e2 we have knight to d7 and now
knight to g3 so going after that a
beautiful f5 square uh black of course
will not allow this place g6 and not do
the castles uh the window goes bishop to
a6 uh now the d3 pawn is kind of stuck
there you can go for some usual c3 d4
ideas so rook to e1 getting the rook out
of this
vulnerable square and now uh castle's
queen side and as usual when we have
castles on opposite sides of the board
the game tends to get a lot more
interesting so bishop to e3 challenging
this bishop and now uh david anton says
all right i don't really mind this if
you capture i'm just going to capture
this even works well for me i want to
re-maneuver my knight over to e6 so he
says adjust h5 but maybe just maybe okay
this is a rapid game so of course they
cannot
invest too much time in a position but
maybe just going back
and now if white ever play something
like c3 or d4 uh you will capture and
this bishop comes alive while white's
dark square bishop isn't really doing
all that much so maybe also something to
consider but okay h5 we have bishop
captures and c5 the dark square bishop
seems to be stronger than the light
square bishop or rather light's dark
square bishop we have captures captures
and now queen to d2 uh bringing the
queen into the attack black did castle
queen side so we might have some ideas
of maybe playing rogue b1 b for opening
up the the queen side and black will try
of course to make his kingside attack
happen before white's king a queen side
attack happened so h4
knight to f1 and now knight to d7 so not
allowing the knight here
uh to be used as a temple for pushing b4
now the queen also guards the b for
square knights the e3 and now comes rook
to h5 uh we have queen to c3 uh and now
king to b7 defending that c6 pawn as the
queen attacked it and now rook to a3 so
you can see that white already has some
very
nice ideas here the rook is coming to b3
knight might be coming to c4 we might
attack the a5 pawn uh so who will be
faster here here we have f6 uh david
anton first improves on his structure
here defends the e5 pawn and now uh the
same thing to do or rather the uh
the thing that should work for white is
rook to b1 uh this prepares b4 and then
we continue now
in that in that fashion of course c5
will be played uh and the black will
prevent this uh but that's why i i'm
calling it the same thing duda goes for
the not for the insane thing but for
definitely not the same thing and that
is knight to c4 now you can see that
there are some uh problems here there
there are uh the the a51 is being
attacked rook might be coming to b3 we
already discussed rook to b1 b4 might be
played
and what you want to do here is simply
allow this you want to play knight to f8
allow your queen to get into the game
and uh if white tries anything uh well
uh two rash then for example knight
captures captures captures you don't
really worry about this you're gonna
play queen d6 and if if a check is given
king to a7 are fine here there is no way
for white to improve the
uh improve the pressure there's no way
to get the knight into the game uh
in any significant way and there's no
just a way to increase the pressure so
uh instead after knight to c4 uh here
anton david anton played queen to b4 and
this is now a problem because this lu
this loses the game on the spot uh so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for duda while i give you a couple
of seconds and yes this is the position
from the thumbnail
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on solving this
well complete mystery and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course knight captures an a5 with
check
uh and here you might think all right
what's so special about this well for
one you are removing or rather you have
removed the defender of the queen so if
black just moves the queen we're gonna
win the win the black queen uh obviously
that's not happening the problem is if
we just play queen captures on a5 which
seems like a perfectly fine idea then
comes the move that always wins the game
for a white most of the times
and that is pawn to b4 pawn to b4 traps
the queen and here black just resigns or
black would resign if this was played
after knight captures an a5 check b
captures on a5 was played but now you
don't get to play b4 and trap the queen
however you do get to play rook to b3
and trap the queen this way so we give
up the knight and rook for a queen and
of course this is completely winning for
duda c5 was played but it is uh
futile just rook captures on b4 c
captures and now queen to b3 going for
queen to f7 to completely wreak havoc
across the board so rook to h7 stopping
this now queen to d5 check uh now we're
picking up the a5 pawn and uh well uh
the the rest uh simply is irrelevant of
what black plays c6 was played queen
captures an a5 and he was in this
position on move 27 that david anton
guihara resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so here you
can see another fine example of
of
how if uh if you were in this position
and black played a queen to b4 uh if you
know that b4 always wins the the game
for white you will easily find this line
of knight captures on a5 because it is
just so simple once you know that b4 is
such a powerful asset in almost any
position uh then the the uh position of
course is uh easily solved uh so i hope
you guys that were able to now to solve
this one brilliant brilliant miniature
by by do that it's basically
2021 move after uh queen to b4 now even
though the game okay was played for a
few more moves but i consider this uh uh
um
below below 25 moves miniature uh so
yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank stefan harris
berger and michael colbert jail england
consulting firebord farraroni and
draper's cyberclub nft for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
charity cup until it ends thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day